قائد الجيوش والبلاد اثناء هجمات التاسع
من سبتمبر ما الذي دار في بالك عندما سمعت
عن انفجارات بامره بوست
تذكرني ذلك بان الشر مازال موجودا وان
هناك اناس في العالم مستعدون للقتل من اجل
سبب لا نعلمه الان ولكننا سنكتشف في
نفس الاسبوع ببلده قريبه من ا وقع انفجار
بمصنع وكلا الحادثتين جعلت ان ان حظا ونحن
على علم بان هناك ان ستتضرر
ماذا تعلمت من اسلافه الرؤساء مثل والدك
والرئيس كلينتون والرئيس كارتر
من المهم ان تعلم ان الحياه لا تتوقف بعد
الرئاسه والتحدي هو كيف تستغل فرصه الحياه
الفرقه وانني كنت وقطع مائه الامنيه
اليوميه انما الان في صف رانيه لكنني
استطيع القول ان مساعدته في ارساء مفاهيم
السلام والحريه وتحسين الوضع الانساني
لقد اشرت في كتابه الى ان هناك اساليب
عسكريه تحتاج الى اعاده التفكير اما امر
ازاله صدام كان قرارا عاقل او منزل تاثر
على انه الافضل فالولايات المتحده الان
اكثر امنا وبامكان العراقيين العيش في
مجتمع حر الان هدفي ليست دفاعا سياسته
وانما توضيح فكره كيف تكون رئيس او تتحمل
مسؤوليه اتخاذ القرارات
التاريخ هو الذي سيحكم على تلك القرارات
بشان العراق يعني انني لن اكون موجوده
ساعه اصدار الحكم النهائي ساكون ميتا
السيده